[Music]
here's your money briefing for Wednesday
March 15th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
February's inflation reading came down a
bit to six percent that's little
consolation for consumers who continue
to pay more and more for things like
groceries and while it wasn't that long
ago when inflation began its sharp climb
many of us have a cloudy memory of how
much cheaper prices actually were in a
moment we'll talk to a Georgetown
University Professor who's co-authoring
a study on why we misremember prices but
first let's bring in wsj personal
finance reporter Joe pinsker Hey Joe
thank you for being with us yeah thank
you for having me so Joe help us fill in
the timeline for a moment even though
we've seen the inflation rate come down
in the past several months what's been
the trend going back to Mid pandemic
yeah so if you look back at the last
couple years prices have and this
probably won't be news to people been
rising at much faster rates than people
are accustomed to in January if you
looked at the Consumer Price Index that
was up 6.4 percent from a year earlier
which is a slightly lower rate than the
very high peak that it hit of 9.1 one
percent last summer in June 2022 so yes
inflation has been slowing a bit but
this doesn't mean that prices are coming
down it just means that they're
increasing a little bit less quickly
than they were in pretty recent memory
wow and so anybody who's currently
shelling out double or triple the amount
that they used to spend on you know for
example their weekly grocery run they
probably remember the good old days when
things were a lot cheaper but how has
the passage of time and in this case not
really a lot of time played with
people's memories absolutely I've been
talking with consumers about how they
feel about the emotional side of a price
increase and it's really interesting I
think in some ways it plays with our
sense of time people are really used to
the idea of prices rising pretty
gradually and so there's a real Whiplash
associated with seeing them rise so
quickly I talked to one guy who watched
the price of his avocados rise from one
dollar a piece to two dollars and fifty
cents over the course of a year and he
said that he kind of felt like was that
a year ago that I encountered that
really low price or was that 10 years
ago these are changes that we're not
used to seeing unfold on such a short
timeline and then in the bigger picture
I think when people are confronted with
these prices that are much higher than
what they're used to one woman I was
talking with was telling me that she
feels this sense of helplessness and
frustration like she was sort of being
asked to confront this problem that she
didn't create but she hasn't been given
any tools to deal with it and instead of
estimating a price from say 2021 they
pull one in their brain from 2018. so
why do people's memories Cloud the past
even the not too distant past let's
bring in Francesco dakunto he's
associate professor of Finance at
Georgetown University and is co-author
of forthcoming research on the matter
Francesco thank you very much for being
with us thank you for having me so
Francesco why is it that people tend to
misremember the price of products when
it wasn't all that long ago that they
were significantly lower yes so this is
something that the psychologists call
proactive interference with a very
complicated term but it's actually very
simple to think about so the idea is
whenever we try to recall something that
has happened in the past given we have
so many memories of things that happened
in the past sometimes we actually tend
to recall things that happened a bit
farther back in time relative to the one
we are we're trying to guess and so in
the case of prices this really has a
systematic effect on what people think
the process they observe and the face
are because we know that prices tend to
increase
systematically over time so if I recall
something that goes farther and farther
back in time I will tend to recall lower
and lower prices and that means that I
will think that inflation is higher and
higher than what it really actually is
so we did a particular survey in 2022
where we asked a very large
representative population of consumers
in the US about what they recalled the
price of milk was 12 months earlier now
we actually have data this shows us the
exact transactions that those people
made over the last 12 months so we find
that more than 20 percent of those
respondents recalls a price of milk that
was one quarter 25 percent lower than
the actual price so on average the price
of milk of the average milk we have in
the sample is about 2.6 US dollars so
that means about 20 percent of the
sample recalls having paid 50 cents less
more or less out of a price of 2.6
dollars so that's quite substantial I
mean when we think about that in
proportions that would imply that they
actually think that inflation was about
like seven eight percent higher than
what the true inflation was almost say
twice as much as the actual rate of
inflation how much of this thought
process has to do with how often
somebody shopped so this we find in the
data actually expliciting particular
relates to grocery shopping habits and
that's somewhat potentially surprising
because instead when we think about what
we spend money on the larger fraction of
our income goes in other types of goods
like utilities restaurants potentially
purchasing cars once in a while large
ticket items so we only spend a small
fraction of our income on groceries
including for example milk and bread but
what we find in the data is that people
really think about those prices very
very often in their mind based on how
frequently they go shopping so how
frequently they see those prices and in
particular for example one regularity we
have in the data is that there is a very
strong gender effect so women for
example typically tend to recall
substantially higher inflation over time
relative to men and we found in our
research this is actually not really
related to gender in any way but it's
related to the fact that on average
women are more likely to attend to
grocery shopping for their households so
for example when we look at the men in
households where actually the man is the
one who does most of the grocery
shopping we immediately find there's
this difference in genders completely
disappears okay now how about life
outside the world of food prices how
common is it for us to misremember
details like these in other areas of
life yes so that happens very often and
across many different domains of life so
for example when we have to try to
recall in which location we wear at a
certain point in time the order of
actions we made for example in a certain
situation that potentially didn't happen
that often ago often people misremember
now a typical example of that is that
you know whenever we have for instance
trials and several different testimonies
try to recall what happened and at the
time of the criminal event of the crime
they might have very different
Recollections of what has happened even
if the crime didn't happen that much
time before so this is really pervasive
it happens very often all right that's
Georgetown University associate
professor of Finance Francesco da Kunta
Francesco thank you very much for being
with us thank you very much for having
me so Joe back to those memories from
the so-called good old days How likely
are we to see prices return to those
wistful days of yesteryear the
unfortunate thing is that we won't
actually see prices decline back down to
the level they were at a couple years
ago across the board but what economists
say and what economists hope and expect
is that over time what's going to happen
is that the price increases every month
and every year will slow down but at the
same time wages will continue to rise
hopefully at a faster rate and so as
that process unfolds over a longer
period of time even though we we might
still have higher prices than we did a
couple years ago those higher prices
might be in general more affordable
because people's pay is higher alright
that's personal finance reporter Joe
pinsker Joe thank you very much for
being with us yeah thanks chair and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]